conan
xxx
[Music]
oh
hey buddy what's going on man oh yeah
i'm just heading over to kyle's house to
pick up my chemistry book
oh yeah yeah
his mom is so hot
dude that would be amazing if that
happened
okay
yeah yeah i will uh call you later later
bro
oh this place is crazy
[Music]
kyle your friend is here
hmm
i guess my son kyle isn't home
[Music]
you must be my son's friend richard
please call me dick
kyle we'll be home
[Music]
did was that just keep going
look okay no he's not home but
why don't you come on in
sure
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do you want me
yeah
yeah
[Music]
have you done
all of your homework
what no no no i haven't done any of my
own first you do piano lesson why is
your english bad all of a sudden you
practice piano now again
again
again you're terrible you must practice
we're gonna have sex after this right
sure
did you do your math homework 2x plus 6
minus 3 multiply by x plus seven equals
one okay go now okay all right but why
does your accent keep going back and
forth shut up wrong
wrong
[Music]
wrong
okay i'm all done i did all the problems
are we gonna have sex now
of course
but first you mow lawn ha ha what
chalemmi brothers
conan triple x